what is the meaning of life are we here
for a reason is there a point to any of
this and lightest food tastes so much
better in the trash this was me and then
this was me then I came back as this
little guy a lot of lives for one dog to
live but I'm getting ahead of myself
let's start at the beginning I'm a new
soul for me it all began with a boy his
name was Ethan Bailey Bailey Vance my
name was Bailey Bailey Bailey Bailey
no come on Bailey do it what does he
want from me no whenever life got Ethan
down I knew exactly what to do hey I'm
ready now played with that ball all
afternoon even loved it
sometimes he just needed a little nudge
don't wow sorry that was the dog that
was me him maybe you should teach your
dog some manners
we spent every day together they
fighting over food no nothing America as
the years went by I could tell my time
with Ethan was coming to an end
good boy Bailey I miss you and then it
happened I was back I didn't have it I'm
a girl good girl good girl I had a new
purpose I was needed again and again and
again hi with each new life I was
learning a new lesson hmm have we met
before
where did you find that okay ready yeah
I tried to make sense out of all the
things I'd see was there a point to this
journey of mine
and how did bacon fit in
if I can get you licking and loving I
have my purpose
even why do you aiways have his dog with
you like a girlfriend replacement or
something look at the dogs laughing at
you
dogs don't laugh that's funny a
beautiful boy we're very proud of
yourself a life I'd forgotten
you okay I had